yo afternoon
walk talk
vessel Edition you can fix it
it can get better
like life is what you decide it is
had a great morning breakfast coffee for
20 minutes with somebody
it's kind of shift his perspective he's
just decided he's gonna focus on all the
bad
you just got to decide to focus on all
the good everybody's got bad and good
every single [__] person's got bad or
good if you envy or do you think
somebody's got it so easy you have mass
confusion everybody has got bad or good
in their life at all times of course it
Ebbs and flows but it's a game about
choosing what's up brother how are you
it's about choosing yeah
of course brother it's about choosing
either what the hell
it's about choosing to decide to look at
the good